un autre panel ce soir on accueille
stéphanie grammond michels et augé et
stéphanie chouinard bonsoir à vous trois
enfants on va commencer en parlant
justement de cette sixième vague qui
serait à nos portes fort malheureusement
parce que pas tellement de gens qui sont
comme beaucoup d'épaisseurs entendre
parler de kobe dans le sait bien mais
qui a tout les vous les chiffres le
montrent ces temps aux travailleurs de
la santé de plus en plus nombreux à être
absents vous avez entendu sans doute
l'entrevue précédente avec docteur
veillette ici le travailleur qui
rappelle les consignes mais y'a combien
quand on entend du docteur boileau de la
santé publique le faire son point de
presse un point presse annoncé un peu à
la surprise il n'a pas fait de mesures
supplémentaires annoncées vont
dorénavant vous devez faire ceci ou cela
il relance vraiment la responsabilité
individuelle
c'est stéphanie grammond je commençais
avec vous là dessus est-ce que puisque
les gens plus envie d'entendre patrick
drevet de caux vd ce que ses appels à la
prudence là ils sont entendus
mais je ne suis pas convaincu parce que
la plupart des mesures sont voraces ont
disparu et on a un peu de télégraphier
aussi de retraite du port du masque en
disant bon ça sera pour la mi-avril
mais quand on regarde les sondages on
voit que les gens au québec se disent 15
quand les camps les cartouches avaient
disparu on va arrêter de suivre les
règles donc seulement 30 % des québécois
qui disent on continuera de porter le
masque une fois que ce sera plus
obligatoire à l'intérieur donc on peut
pas imaginer là que c'est un gros ou une
grosse adhésion pour le monde plus sûr
si on finit par être tout seul à le
porter peut-être en voie on va avoir un
peu le le dieu le tour de corse sort
exactement et puis c'est intéressant
parce qu'au québec c'est chez nous que
cette proportion n'est hélas plus
faibles plus qu'en alberta plus qu'au
canada donc il faut il faut espérer que
la campagne de sensibilisation où on dit
aux gens faut apprendre à vivre avec le
avec le virus un qu'ils soient et
quelles soient plus respectés parce que
pour l'instant les signes qu'on à son
port son mât cet effet là michel
beaucoup ce point princière l'allemand
avec monsieur boileau tout seul qui a
pas d'annoncé à faire
je pense qu'il voulait sincèrement viril
et faites attention c'est possible mais
ce n'est pas ce que les gens de ce
serment au compliquer si la même façon
quand les gens comprennent vivre avec le
virus y comprennent pas nécessairement
que on doit que faire continuer de faire
attention continue à porter le mastic le
virus circule vivent avec le virus est
devenu pour bien des gens la traduction
des straub les mesures ce qui n'est pas
exactement la même chose alors je pense
que
essayer de ne pas de poids de dire on a
encore un problème pour cent voire
probable mail du probable
je peux sûr que son message a été bien
bien compris mais je pense que cécile de
tshela concentre ses fans et chun a
maintenant il doit pas avoir beaucoup
d'appétit pour aucun gouvernement au
canada de toute façon de remettre en
place des mesures et c'est encore plus
vrai sans doute pour les provinces qui
bascule en année électorale
oui tout à fait en ontario on l'a vu
dans le courant du mois de mars le
premier ministre de cesser débarrasser
plus rapidement que ce à quoi
on s'attendait des mesures sanitaires
alors même que bon on n'en parle pas
encore mais il semblerait alors qu'une
sixième vague à nos portes et le
problème en ontario actuellement ses
comptes est très peu pour vous donner un
élément de comparaison au plus fort la
cinquième vague en ontario ont testé les
tests pcr soixante quinze mille
personnes par jour actuellement on est à
peu près dix mille personnes qui passent
des tests pcr et donc les chiffres
officiels sont probablement très loin de
la réalité
est ce que ce qui nous indique en fait
qu'on est très loin de la réalité c'est
aussi les eaux usées qui sont testés
dans les grandes villes comme ottawa
comme toronto où on demande que dans
plusieurs quartiers les les infections
sont effectivement en hausse bon alors
ça c'est notre outil effectivement qu'on
ne plus au québec qu'on va sans doute
relancer d'après ce que je comprends les
vip stage des eaux usées mais que bien
des experts revendiquait pas ce que dit
à défaut test au moins ça donne une
sorte de baromètre ça nous dit où on en
est rendu il reste que
si jamais cette vague le monter c'est
fanny g en un moment donné va falloir
que je vais pouvoir qu'il ya des
consignes peut-être un petit peu plus
dur peut-être qu'on va être obligé de
renforcer un petit peu les choses ceci
dit dans une année électorale au québec
c'est un petit peu le fonds de commerce
éric duhaime avec le parti conservateur
de dénoncer les mesures et de dire que
le gouvernement a deux le gouvernement
du québec serait mail prix de ce sermon
tu es vraiment ben oui puis en plus cela
avec la avec la loi on a laissé tomber
les lois qui permettait d'agir par
décret et on dit on ne remettra pas de
mesure populationnelle et donc ils vont
être ils vont être vraiment coincé si si
si mais quand remonte à un point tel
qu'on voit les hôpitaux débordés qu'on
voit le nombre de décès elle s'est
surtout je crois les plus vulnérables
les personnes âgées celles qui ont des
maladies chroniques
auxquels il faut faire attention où vous
pourrez pas que il ya une hécatombe
encore mais bon évidemment on n'est pas
encore rendu là il faut faire un faux
pas des choses une à la fois peut-être
que on aura finalement là c'est sûr
l'été arrive le problème en est que ce
soit - p11 espérons le ouais c'est vrai
que ça laisse peu de marge de manoeuvre
pour les gouvernements oui parce que
vous parlez du prêteur mais je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui la température qu'on
a c'est loin d'être fini parlant de
l'autre sujet ce qui était ce qui
attirait l'attention aujourd'hui fin de
la saga peut-être on verra sur le
remplacement de la flotte des vieux
avions de l'armée canadienne des avions
qui ont maintenant 40 ans qui semble sur
les tonnages vraiment vénération pour
une vision de chasse c'est fini je vous
entends là-dessus stéphanie chouinard
est ce que vous pensez vraiment alors le
gouvernement trudeau se tourner vers les
f 35
on voudrait 88 de la compagnie
américaine lockheed martin on va entamer
des négociations a mis de l'argent de
côté là dessus est ce qu'on sente
vraiment vers la fin de la saga
mais on l'espère du point de vue des
forces armées canadiennes il faut voir
que c'est pas parce qu'on arrive près du
but qu'on y est tout à fait humain même
si les négociations aboutissent les
premiers avions ne seront pas livrés
avant 2025 donc on peut pas dire le
compartiment qu à une prochaine mission
de l'otan demain matin avec ses nouveaux
avions là l'élément principal qui
demeure à négocier actuellement c est ce
que lockheed martin être en mesure
d'assurer au gouvernement qu'une partie
de ces 19 milliards de dollars seront
dépensés au canada une partie de cette
flotte là qui sera construite en sol
canadien lorsqu'on parle de dangereux
d'approvisionnement pour les forces
armées canadiennes c'est toujours la
grande question à ce que l'économie
canadienne va bénéficier et pour le
moment la kids martin ne semble pas être
en mesure d'offrir cette garantie le
gouvernement donc c'est vraiment le
dernier point d'achoppement avant qu'on
arrive mais si on monte un petit peu le
fil du passé mais cherchez pas les mêmes
avions que
le gouvernement libéral avait promis de
ne pas acheter c'était sûr au départ qui
était visé par le gouvernement européens
où il y avait de la controverse autour
de six avions là et mener les moteurs
ge et du ciel qui était chef du bloc à
ce moment là
il y avait eu toutes sortes de choses
stephenie a tout à fait raison là on
commence la vraie affaire qui est
retombé et une fois qu'on a dit on va
faire des retombées au canada il ya un
deuxième débat qui va s'engager c'est où
gt gt à ottawa quand on a acheter les
avions actuels s'il ya très longtemps
c'était pas mal de la première cape à 80
et il y avait des députés libéraux
fédéralistes et ou qui
se déchire et la chemise si au québec
n'a pas sa part de retombées de cannes
adversaire sera d'être pertinent pour le
québec
c'est pour vous donner une idée de l'art
pur qui peut se faire
dans une débauche où vont aller les
retours ben ouais alors ses fans est
grave finalement il ya des écrits
politiques là derrière
oui ben c'est toujours un sujet de débat
évidemment puis l'hymne et gouvernement
ont mal géré
après les autres la question des
dépenses militaires ça a toujours été un
peu
malheureusement une blague tant pour les
frégates temps pour les sous-marins on
n'a pas eu énormément de talent
évidemment on a sabré dans les dépenses
militaires comme tous les pays du monde
depuis 35 ans la part du des dépenses
militaires par rapport au pib a fondu de
moitié la faim partout sur la planète et
le canada encore plus est donc là
probablement qu'on va on voit dans le
prochain budget la avoir une lecture l'a
tué savoir ce qu'on va remonter les
dépenses militaires au niveau de ce que
le temps je souhaiterais voir on a déjà
des indications dans le sens le puy yeux
il ya d'autres demandes parce que l'on
parle les avions chance mais aussi à
toute la chaîne de radars dans le nord
du canada la norad tous au top un peu un
en ruine et puis d'avril avec la garant
du canon et alice connor nous on un
voisin qui s'appelle la russie est bon
ça veut pas dire qu'ils vont nous
envahir demain matin un milieu quand
même de plus en plus d'exploration pour
les ressources naturelles
en arctique et si on n'est pas là pour
pour faire valoir nos droits mais ça
peut poser problème ça comme change un
petit peu la perception de ce que ça
veut dire renouveler la ses capacités
d'armement dans un pays comme le canada
avec ce conflit en ukraine où l'on se
rend compte que les choses peuvent
basculer on le voit dans la perception
du public aussi parlons de l'ontario est
la seule province qui s'était pas encore
entendu avec le gouvernement fédéral sur
son programme national de garderies
alors là ils viennent là signé l'entente
aujourd'hui bien sûr les parents vont
être les grands gagnants ça coûte cher
semble sûr c'est ce que notre collègue
nous dit ça coûte très cher les frais de
garderie en ontario mais c'est fini
cheminant sur le plan politique est-ce
que les deux premiers ministres le
premier ministre ontarien premier
ministre hugo sont tous les deux
gagnants mais c'est certain que pour
pour monsieur trudeau il ya un an lors
du dépôt du budget on était tous un peu
dubitatif à savoir est ce que le
gouvernement fédéral va vraiment être en
mesure de signer des ententes avec dix
provinces et trois territoires et
finalement les plus récalcitrants ça a
été l'ontario la housse a coûté le plus
cher au pays effectivement c'est
au-dessus de 2000 $ par mois en frais de
garde ries en moyenne dans la province
donc assez rien de moins qu'une
révolution des portefeuilles des
familles qui va avoir vu dans les
prochaines années mais pour monsieur
foraine c'est aussi une petite victoire
parce qu'ils étaient récalcitrants parce
qu'il espérait avoir un petit peu plus
que ce qui avait été mis sur la table
l'année dernière donc on octroie 1 3
milliard supplémentaire une année
supplémentaire donc une sixième année de
financement de la part du gouvernement
fédéral il faut voir que cette entente
là elle arrive vraiment à la 11e rang
parce que sinon on était possible au 1er
avril une partie de ces fonds là qui
disparaît c est ça je me demande si les
parents en ontario vont s'en souvenir le
jour des élections le 2 juin prochain à
savoir si on va récompenser monsieur
ford avoir finalement trouvé un terrain
d'entente avec monsieur trudeau ou si on
veut punir de nous avoir fait attendre
ou selon la direction mais si michel
je suis folle n'avait pas tellement le
choix juge parce qu'ils pouvaient pas
aller en campagne avec un sourire de
match et ces sondages sont pas mauvaises
leçons comment et quand je fais un
populaire non plus ne pouvait pas aller
l'a10 à toutes les autres provinces tous
les autres territoires tout le monde est
signé la feuille puis vous l'avais pas
fait je suis folle pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi est il le dit
il y avait une étude la banque scotia
n'avait pas assez qui disait que les
frais de garde à l'ontario est en train
de devenir le poste budgétaire numéro 1
des familles devant le logement ce qui
est ce qui est pour rien il attend quand
on regarde le budget d'une famille alors
c'est quelque chose qui s'était besoins
clients et pour ça monsieur trudeau lui
rapporte qu'à menacer une assez grande
victoire parce que c'est quelque chose
que les libéraux plus à faire depuis
longtemps pas le marché avait négocié
avec toutes les provinces juste avant
d'être battus en chambre sur les
commandites
mais c'est quelque chose qu'il a le
programme libéral depuis longtemps oui
j'ai juste vérifier s'il me reste encore
du temps oui il reste une minute le
temps vous montrer un tweet qui a
vraiment étonné beaucoup de gens un
tweet de jason kenny qui est une
allusion à la spectaculaire jivko
données où elle se met hier à cet
humoriste qui avait eu une blague
douteuse sur sa blonde alors il la relie
lui à toutes ses politiques
environnementales qui touche l'industrie
du pétrole s'est fanée grandmont
réaction là dessus
moi je pense que c'est un parallèle qui
est extrêmement douteux je vois pas
pourquoi on récupérer un événement
malheureux comme celui qui s'est passé
ou aux oscars hier l'académie a
d'ailleurs condamné une geste 1 de wells
limite alors je trouve que c'est bien
mal avisé de la pente du zune kenny de
récupérer ça de cette façon là oui un
second de réaction l'autre stéphanie oui
on a l'impression que c'est un petit
gars de 12 ans qui est derrière le tweet
de monsieur pianiste est absolument
indigne d'un premier ministre
manifestement c'était trop tentant ce
sera donc le mou de la famille si
beaucoup stéphanie stefani michelle
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
voilà au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit